a little weird gathering things over
Thank You scientist boom-boom sauce
cookie wrappers a little variant of tea
water milk I'll tell you this my life is
filled with sauce and sweet it's like
you opened a hell of fresh box that you
have no clue drinking I think this thing
makes a pipe bomb mr. bonfire Comedy
Central radio sirius XM 95 big Jay
oakerson that's Dan Soder hi the whole
crew is here joining us the studio today
you know I'm everyone you love them
there's no need for introduction
anywhere people just say to throw him a
third Mike and Shane Gillis everybody
yeah some column the the Tom he's the
Benjamin Franklin of sheets Nations I've
traveled for wide Mechanicsburg
Stroudsburg Carlsberg hell yeah it's
been two hours is naming all the birds
of Pennsylvania love and we love when
Shane Gillis is here of course yeah you
came in on a day we he moved a needle
the reason Shane's on the show today is
cuz he moved the needle and he
got us in touch we got a styrofoam box
of sheets could this be an eye a
an explosion maybe we have seen here
today for the unveiling of an offering
what else do you call it I mean a
temptation I just want to say real quick
from people it cheats them so Wow
yeah don't talk about well hasn't
acknowledged this at all let's you want
to open this up
you mentioned sheets name next oh my god
it's the head of Nikki Glaser they did
it they sent us in a package with a note
that says sorry's is sorry this isn't
more official yet I would have sent some
boneless wings or popcorn chicken over
but I'm guessing you probably don't have
a deep fryer in the studio of your
office's he's right but we are working
on that
we'll figure something out we'll figure
something better out soon in the
meantime I'll keep those packages coming
with different food in this package
here's what we have right here this is
insane break the stuff you know these
things here yeah Shane what are these
total sauces no no I mean I have the
list here what they are so I could tell
you but
you can tell us what if these things are
good you tell me Shane
there's reverse chocolate chip cookies
yeah they're good you can you can see it
it looks good never had one you can see
it though white-chocolate macadamia-nut
correct choice nominal Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup cookies pepperoni rolls that
need to be heated up in the oven or
toaster I mean those are gonna be on eat
those pepper oils straight out of the
garbage bag they mailed them to us
what's this that's the way to keep it
cold Dan's never seen things and here's
the three other things they sent Dan see
they answer your question there's a
jalapeno ranch
yeah sauce there's boom-boom sauce which
is their that's their thing that's which
he says this this boom boom ah that's
good I don't want it by the way there's
a secret recipe next to boom-boom sauce
that I'm not gonna read out loud what it
is wait they got it in there
it just says he says more or less what
it is it's sort of like going like if
some of those McDonald's McDonald's
secret sauce and you go it's basically
found yeah what's this oh that's got to
be the secret right no do you know what
no you know that is a barbecue what kind
I'll table kind Hickory spicy Dr Pepper
barbecue okay you know what Sheetz it's
been nice doing business with you but
you take your circus flavors out
of here you ever have Jack Daniel did
you Dan
did you ever have Jack Daniel's sauce
from Friday's yeah I eat your
dick with that yeah me too
you want to do that yeah man I knew
where to get laid all these all these do
so many cookies tonight um by the way
cookies don't think cameras is sent to
us and you're gonna love this this is
sent to us from Alex Hawk who I know is
a camper an awesome guy I mean this is
do you want to know do you wanna know as
titled am what MTO culinary research and
development man research by the way
where the you I don't know if you
know this Dan that means we know the guy
at least who's next to the guy who could
green light a bonfire fire sandwiches
some sort
get all I mean I just got cookie this is
she well we appreciate you dude if you
guys get a bonfire sandwich
that'll be my low point although like if
I in the future quit comedy and the guys
buy any goes hey crackle crackle and go
just take the change you should be a
house Finnegan I'm the thing is
dead dude doesn't know who you are
cookies well throw me one stop
talking about it well trying to get it
away from God dr. pepper barbecues also
I'm here I don't want this I'm trying to
give anybody I see what you've already
given out it's to you don't
want me I'm gonna kick it across the
room to him stacks thank you there's so
many options right now just because go
on and throw me white macadamia I go go
on I go Jay look another white macadamia
these are all yours you could have all
these yeah oh hey also I gonna taste
like off medicine it says here also
hoping that look this is the diet mmm
it's a good dense cookie ain't no they
don't
great texture welcome to the family
sheets look at my pants throwing us
campers by all means send in your kid
pictures it always makes us laugh this
kid pictures no doubt picture in a no
doubt thing that's who wanna go over all
the kids especially your mom don't tell
your mommies or daddies or both gonna be
in trouble just sandy come on you're big
now
dude boom-boom sauce I kind of want to
take this home that's not boom-boom
oranges that's how a pina ranch this
jalapeno ranch yeah I kinda want to take
this boom boom home black glue how do we
split it between the two of us you know
I mean I gotta go juice pop you a
swindle sauce for the bust man I just
wanted to taste it yeah well I mean I
would like to take it home but I imagine
have to keep it cool and I have to go to
have to go to spots so I can't make a
bring these cookies with me
over here okay yeah and me and Christina
blue your camel cool dude I know that I
know facetiousness when you say it being
a sheet sauce meal was actually a pretty
respectable profession there's nothing
wrong Oh mr. big thinks be the
sheets mules also notice we make a
living I'm sorry the flip chocolate-chip
cookie is unbelievable pretty impressive
I'm gonna do what Jacob said I'm gonna
have a little I'm gonna try a little bit
of this barbecue sauce you think it's
like Cosby's barbecue sauce does it get
the ladies all hippy jiffy how is that
what he said something like that right
what do you think fine Bill Cosby Oh
fine Bill Cosby defends rape on Cosby
Show everybody gets a little drop my bum
they get all tricking to drink that i
massaged the language this barbecue
sauce could be used in a marinade or
just straight-up dude he just Wow black
leaders took a shot of it black Lew I
swear he went off right now if you just
chug just did that
for t he just went back like a 40 no
you know slam dunking cons you
drink like it's weight we have a brown
paper bag we can wrap it in first yeah
is there a peanut butter cup cookie I
was about to break into one you want if
you find a way to reach into Dan's bag
and grab it out that'd be great white
chocolate macadamia dude I've been
hearing out walking a minute
yo chill dude
dan dan you're too hyped up dude chill
then you're too wired up don't you try a
little bit of my barbecue sauce I got
one you know you try the barbecue sauce
Kibo huggy buggy everywhere it's funny
that buggy this is what he thought being
romantic was yeah they were like now you
act like this is a sexual scene in there
like right maybe a little less rapey
being real Raby how many you know how
many karate chops to the carotid artery
I've saved BBQs oh hey Bill we're over
in video village comes off real rapey
what'd you say to your wife I just wanna
know if if you're I mean it's your show
but I saw you with a non eyedropper or
over crafty drug just put something on
all the crispy treats
that's my barbecue sauce Friday evenings
I like to be the Zamboni and clean up
all the dead bodies around crafty come
through and I'll make sure the ISIS dog
he's the time for a second we have to go
second bro yeah but I want to keep
eating cookie what better time you got
to leave yeah I guess I'll leave dude if
you want me to did later dude
dude I brought you this I made this I
made this look at what I brought
I delivered this upon your feet this
cookies and sauces from mechanicsburg at
your table hang out as long as you can't
we're gonna take our next break we'll be
right back into the bonfire bonfire
coming to the radio sirius XM 95 big Jay
oakerson Dan Soder Shane Gillis join
change sheets Gilles Joyce let's do it
Oh - Christine warmed up some of the
pepperoni oh really
pep rolls fresh out of the
mic the record I want to say before we
try these I want to be fair to sheets
and say we were told to toaster oven or
oven
they did not say microwave I worry about
how it's gonna come out do you think
this is gonna greatly affect how you you
judge him I might judge harshly look at
all these cookies though some Christine
went to go cook bountiful expedition you
get a little boob sauce on your thing
are you really that did this like a good
idea I don't think it's what it's for
boom boom and pet might not mix yeah
that's what cheese is all about is
innovating and expanding this type of
attitude that will get you into Altoona
I'm sorry I'm a creative type well it's
a Silicon Valley it literally tastes
like the Stromboli I make well that's a
compliment
I like a mean ash Trimboli it suits you
it's good cheese
I think you might be looking at a new
member you're just jumping over of
sheets nation no wow I mean we move as a
family we all know that we move as a
family we're a Wawa family well no now
we're in between people just sending
these in alone what the sauces I mean I
mean from the reef research and
development sector that's really J
that's like you know it's just people
give a dude there's guys in
camouflage lab coats right now how to
get the new pepper lab there's someone
right now busting his ass in rural
Pennsylvania deep deep in a lab guys how
about a to cheese's I'm sorry I'm just a
janitor here but hello Derek Jerry come
here how long you been here long I was a
Sheets mule for ten years and then why
don't you tell me how a
boom-boom sauce mule mmm coming here
work as a costume you have better ideas
than you Rick why don't you tell me how
that's possible this is a good will
hunting but with sandwiches that'll kill
you they won't kill you should you
mouth Beth then don't say it
again no you guys have to make the
switch now this is pretty look at this
it's good it's obvious what's happening
here one doesn't give a the one
that was there in from your faces and
does I'm just a boy I love you and then
[Music]
your greasy hands on your jeans
before cookies over Jacob we have to
make a decision on who yeah sorry
outlaw country 90 whatever yeah Shane
went full of tackles blasts through the
wall why can't you have a piece I can't
I'm just give a bite goodbye the
business dude that's not a good feeling
I'm here it's great the cookies are
great the sauce is great you gotta cook
man enough did everybody else try the
pepperoni roll I didn't get to try the
peanut butter cup cookie yeah go go good
if you're just eating the pepperoni roll
good I mean you want heartburn
immediately you wanna get hurt I think
changes dip this cookie in the oil yeah
boom boom yeah yeah peanut butter cup
boom boom sauce jalapeno ranch jalapeno
ranch I'll tell you this bad for the
reflux great for the taste buds
what is it gets real chest heat right I
got you a pocket understand a few after
this I'm gonna be doing a benefit
burpees they put ten slim jims
into each one of those yo man don't pull
the curtain don't pull the sheet it's
hurting you right now I'm getting
through it
one glass of milk I would love one do
you have them maybe they yeah got milk
all me I don't know why are you going
around offering glasses of milk if you
got one on you Christine went upstairs
to prepare pepperoni rolls I'm sure
she'll make a milk run we got sweet
bottled water dude that's not gonna help
that makes things worse you know that
cuts right through it
jalapeno sauce is a good base it's a
great base after you have pepperoni
rolls they would eat that as he goes as
Winston Churchill once said when going
through hell keep going has sheets got
the cure for what ails you
yeah take a little swig of that right
there's put gas on the fire did we get
an official black Luke took a swig of
barbecue sauce did you give a review
overall where'd you think honestly
yeah um it's very nice the kitchen put
that together there's no soul that
barbecue sauce it was a white guy but
while he was cooking he was gone Mama's
in the kids there's just a guy pounding
on a door to get in go he's going take
this out to the workers and have them
tell me thing is good the white workers
the ones that drive trucks yeah boom
boom sauce is good and I like this with
the ranch combo Christy here a sauce
person
boom boom sauce good I've not tried the
boom boom you love what boom boom sauces
you know what boom boom you try and you
love what it is ingredients wise yeah I
can't figure out what boom so shut your
mouth dude I nailed this it's pretty
easily color delete the footage you're
guessing that by look no what are you a
detective she goes this sauce died five
days ago there was a struggle when the
sauce was made I could taste it be great
of Christine nailed that there was the
voice divorce in the air she owes one of
them was jealous the other one tried to
run ended in a murder-suicide one bullet
to his wife one boat to his own head
hence the name boom boom and also pay as
well with a turkey sandwich ordered on a
computer dealing with reflux I got the
cure for what ails you oh dude
I mean sheets is gonna be a reflux
there's nothing dislocation you just got
a small case the sheets cut get some
citrus skull get some skull to the face
take it to the face do you don't even
know what you're doing a whole bag of
tasty cakes I now do probably to some
degree flushes you out what it does it's
like chlorine in a pool spiderwebs a
bloodshot yeah I just crank that a do I
almost can you hear on dry land
I took a CodeRed to the dough extreme
effects fertility oh they're saying the
Diet Mountain Dew it it's a theory well
that's what yeah we use that I'm sorry
it affects fertility that's it that's a
that's Plan B where I'm sure you do
if you're not in check get some cold
some cold mountain dude knock that
kid right now just do things you
make your squat over it drop a couple
Mentos let's go to Delco abortion at
dalco Plan B wait Mountain Dew or you
just Bertha X Games athlete the kid
survives the kid air guitar is out of
his mom's couch or while doing the Angus
Young step what's up my name is Colby
and I'm ready to do backflips on a 50cc
dirt bike mr. Jacob always distracts me
wheezing I can't we can't talk about
ac/dc like that he just storms off we
can't you got to leave no no I'm gonna
say whatever gets a he always Jacob
never gets up like wow this is fun so
far I go do something he always goes
it's always a guy problem you know he
gets up like a parent or a little kid
grab something or you guys yes you see
it right it's very I'm always like
what's going on we said something wrong
there's these mad at me you can't talk
about you can't talk about Angus Young
cover the head of a
see my hand here's that guy's the leader
why are they doing this to you dude I
was actually making something very funny
for a promo on our sheets confirmation
day this is what's your confirmation
name our Catholic confirmation shoes
like the Saints at nail salon I used to
be Dennis I want to be Kenneth going
Kenny Kenny Kenny's a good sheets
confirmation name is powerful Kenny and
I were going Kenny
I want to go Daryl Daryl okay yeah
shouldn't our confirmation names be
buck and Oscar oh yeah Oscar yeah
sure my dad won an Emmy buck and his dad
wanted to name him Oscar Oscar said he
was gonna send my forehead you start off
a double O then Oscar the Grouch man you
would have been dragged through the dirt
out of it by the way there was a super
heavyset black kid in my school
named Oscar so he would do but it was
Oscar Brown it wasn't too good last name
Oscar oakerson it just sounds like so it
sounds like words you could say with
tuba notes and buck soda is the name of
a young father for sure there's a knife
in his boot as a kid 14 definitely drove
way young everything was too young my
dad let me take the truck out you gotta
leave I gotta get ya
st. Gilles everybody goes are the best
you know from the show fair when is what
you're gonna go do it now yeah over on
the Anthony cumbia Network or Matt and
Shane's secret podcast cheats nation
shout-out fan shout out zushio we ought
to suck your dick alright
zangoose everybody let's take our last
break we'll come back take this thing
all the way to 8 p.m. Eastern Eastern
not it's the bonfire
[Music]
you